and his bodyguards at this point are
standing back there kind of laughing you
know so you turn around y'all quit
laughing so
he said all right all right all right
ease up I'd do it
well I mean how many commercials have
you done let's see it's been about
[Music]
275 now
oh you have the exact count no not
exactly okay okay
yeah and and what span of time
since uh 1984. oh good year yeah I guess
my first commercial was um
well my first national was 1984.
and I did a commercial with James Brown
The Godfather of Soul you know ow James
Brown
I did that commercial with him and it
wouldn't we introduced
chicken McNuggets
they had just come out and we did one of
the first commercials for chicken
McNuggets
and uh I was in Chicago and uh that's
why I was living at the time
and uh
that was a my big shot you know because
I hadn't done anything like in Michigan
where I was from I had done a
a local business school commercial that
was really nothing so
that I didn't count that but
I did to McDonald's in 1984 and uh
I was like so excited and I was saying I
can't be this lucky
and of course he showed up like four
hours late
so I'm sitting there and I'm like
worried I'm like oh man I knew this was
gonna happen
so he shows up
and they have everything set up the
lights you know the cameras everything
and they say to him the director whose
name was Sid Myers who was the top
commercial director at that point
he said uh well I'm glad you're here
James could you go stand on your mark he
says I thought I told y'all to call me
Mr Brown I'm like oh
so he immediately went and sat down on
one of the little chairs at McDonald's
you know the little chairs
and he wouldn't do anything
so the art director from that agency
came over
the director begged him and the
copywriter everybody from the Ad Agency
came over to try to get into work so I'm
like saying wait a minute
this is a National Commercial this is my
first big break and I had been living in
Chicago for a few months
and I had no money and I was like doing
survival work I like was a painter and
plasterer
because as I as a teenager a man in my
neighborhood was a contractor who owned
a painting and Plastering company so
during the summer he would bring all the
kids in and teach us how to paint and do
that and we got paid you know a little
money
and so I knew that kind of trade so I
got a job doing that
and so that was basically what I was
doing but I mean I was there to try to
become an actor and whatnot
so um
I said well I see this is not going to
go well so I went over to
Mr Brown
and he has his two big bodyguards
standing behind him and they looked at
me I'm like oh no no just I just want to
ask some questions
I said excuse me Godfather he says uh
what I said uh
could you please you know help us you
know this is like my my first big
commercial I just moved here a few
months ago and all of us you know we
trying to make it like you you know we
trying to get get ourselves going and
everything he said well I ain't doing
nothing everybody always want me to do a
damn Shuffle I ain't shoveling yet
and you know he started talking like
that so then I was like oh
so then I turned the walk away and then
I came back I said
aren't you the Godfather of Soul he said
Oh Brother come on I said no no no wait
a minute I say you sow brother number
one
I said when I was a little kid and we
had parties we couldn't get the girls to
dance with us until we put on one of
your records which was really true
and the girls would dance with us
because you know little girls don't like
little boys and whatnot and the boys are
like okay I Gotta Dance So when you put
his stuff on Everybody Get Up and Dance
he said really I said yeah I said come
on Godfather so by this time the other
actors picked up on what I was doing
they said Godfather Godfather Godfather
and his bodyguards at this point are
standing back there kind of laughing you
know so you turn around and y'all quit
laughing so
he said all right all right all right
he's up I do it typical James Brown like
you know how they put the cape on him
anything once he started doing his
little dance and all that shuffled and
all that stuff it couldn't stop him he
said get this in the director said keep
the camera rolling so they shot all of
this stuff
but the interesting thing about the
whole shoe was the fact that after every
take
his wife who was like his stylist would
come out and fluff and comb his hair
after every take so you can imagine
we're doing like a hundred takes
she comes out and the thing is what was
so funny is she had on this tight black
dress like Morticia Adams and she would
come out like that and we'd be standing
there like okay
and she would come out and do his hair
because you know he had that hair you
know and she'd do that and then she
do a little walk off each take
so he got to the point where we were
there all day
and so at that point I didn't really
understand
the money aspect about
you want to stay on the shoot
as long as you can you want to get in
there over eight nine hours because then
you go into overtime you get into time
and a half double time triple time so we
were there like 14 hours
so I was like man I'm tired and once I
got the check I realized that I made
more in overtime
that I made for the actual session fee
so that was my first experience so after
that I was like
I want to stay on these things as long
as I can I mean I'll wear myself out but
you get paid
so after the commercial after we shot it
I said thank you he came up and said
yeah thank you I've been a little upset
with these people I said oh yeah okay I
can imagine so I said is there any way I
can get a signed picture from my niece
he gave me a signed picture and he's
really nice after that
so that was my first commercial I did
you know many years ago
and have you ever tried to approach
quote unquote this like a level Talent
like that ever again or was was that
something being green and just being
human with him it just happened in that
one moment well no I had never and I
haven't done that since then because I
haven't really had a reason to do that
but that was a situation where
I'm I'm you know new in town and I'm
staying with an uncle of mine in his
family and he got these little kids that
were just bad you know like little kids
you know and I'm like oh I gotta get out
of here so I needed to get some money so
I can get my own place but I was
thankful of my my mother's youngest
brother of course I was thankful for
them to let me stay with them while I
was trying to get my feet wet but no I
had never done that I mean since then
I've worked with a lot of a lot of big
people and I know after and I know
protocol you don't you don't say
anything to these people approaching
anything
but I really like I really didn't know
any better but I just came up to him
because I was like
and the funny thing is the Ad Agency
said to me after that the people from
that ages said
we're not going to forget you for this
thank you so much you know you hear that
all the time I'm like yeah all right
whatever
a month later
it's like about 150 degrees because we
shot that commercial in the summertime
and in Chicago like the Midwest when
it's
July and August is unbearable the
humidity is crazy so about a month later
in August
I'm in Chicago
at my uncle's house you know and I'm
just you know doing stuff around the
house you know helping clean up the mess
other kids you know because they all in
school I'm by myself there
and I get a call and my agent is like oh
I'm glad I caught you I said oh what's
going on you got to get downtown right
away I'm like what they say you got to
get down that to Beth rebado to the
casting agency you got to get there they
need to see you I'm like oh so I get my
stuff together and I don't have a car so
I get on the get on the bus get over to
the train which is the Dan Ryan which is
the train and I catch the train down
there I get into place I open the door
and the casting director runs up and I
mean I'm sweating like a pig she she
comes up she's I said what's going on
she says they need to see you in there
right away
so I walk in this room and it's all of
those people that were
on the McDonald's shoot
and the art director he says
we told you we weren't going to forget
you and the commercial turned out to be
Crest toothpaste and it was an
award-winning spot where we lost the
Clio which is like the top it's like the
Oscars of commercials we lost that
commercial award to
where's the beef remember the clear
pillar at Wendy's that that won
everything but we came in second to that
and after that I started doing all kind
of stuff after that
oh for that company for all the
companies oh I mean I just started
because see the funny thing is about
like commercials
once the once did people see you
like other ad agencies or other products
once they see you they they'll call you
in or they tend to want to use you
because the thing is you know in our
business nobody wants to really take a
chance on anybody
so you know when somebody takes a chance
on you then other people say oh well
they took a chance on him so
yeah it's like dating you know you know
most women don't want you if no other
women don't want you
it's just how that is you know so I
started doing a lot of commercial stuff
and then I started doing plays in
Chicago as a theater town you know it's
like um it's like the second theater
town then I studied in Second City
you know I studied um and I got to meet
um Bill Murray Bill Murray's brother
Joel was in my class you know when I was
studying that second City so Bill Murray
would come into town from Saturday Night
Live
and he would take us all to to dinner
and everything because you know he's
Rich so he would take us all because his
little brother was in our class and he
would have us he would entertain us and
everything he was just as funny as he
could be now he's gotten a little jaded
over the years I mean you know it's got
a little different but but but he was
really nice I mean he's still cool from
what I'm here but uh you know I met him
I met um
at the time Belushi was alive John
Belushi I met all of them because they
would all come back to town
and they would go work out at Second
City you know work on stuff and play
around and you know hang out and stuff
so I got to meet a lot of people like
that
and I studied improv over there for a
couple of years and my big regret is
that I didn't go on row on the road they
wanted me to go on the road with one of
the touring companies
but I was doing at that point so well
commercially
on camera commercials and voice over
that it was hard for me to leave that
money and I regret it to this day
because one of the guy a couple of the
guys that went in my place ended up
becoming you know Stars off of that you
know like
but you know hey it's
you you make choices you know